CARTER MORGAN: One of the first
problems Critter Junction had
to solve was packaged delivery.
Once they made a
change to code, how
would it get deployed to
users in a scalable fashion?
Let's look at how Critter
Junction implemented
a gated, tag-based
CI/CD pipeline.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When Critter Junction
was just a prototype,
bundling up their app and
sharing it with the testing
team was fairly simple.
The coders could
just email a link
to the application running
on their dev machines.
But as the application and
its development team grew,
that was no longer feasible.
Manually testing and deploying
changes to the codebase
became a bottleneck
for the team.
Without a reliable,
mostly automatic process
to build tests and update their
microservice-based application,
Critter Junction
just wasn't going
to be able to scale to
the level they dreamed of.
So they implemented
a CI/CD pipeline
using Cloud Build, Google's
serverless CI/CD platform,
and Spinnaker, an open-source
continuous delivery platform.
This allowed them to rapidly
iterate and test the codebase.
The high level steps of this
pipeline are as follows.
A developer changes code and
pushes it to a repository.
Cloud Build detects the
changes, builds a Docker image,
tests the image, and pushes
the image to artifact registry.
Spinnaker detects
that image, deploys it
to a staging environment,
and tests the deployment.
After all tests have
passed, the release manager
can manually approve
the build and deploys
the image to production.
Let's look at each
of these steps.
First, the team was
already using Git
to manage their source code.
As is common in game dev, they
store binary assets elsewhere
and pull those in
when a build occurs.
Using Git allows
devs to check out
a new branch of the codebase
to do their work in before
merging it back to the main
branch after it's tested.
This lets developers easily
work with other developers
and gives you a lot of
flexibility in your workflow.
Critter Junction took
advantage of Git tags
to create a CI/CD pipeline that
kicks off whenever a new tag is
pushed into the Git repository.
They use Cloud Build to produce
application binary and set up
a trigger to watch for any
commits with a Git tag prefixed
with the letter "v."
In addition to commits
with a specific tag,
triggers can look for commits
on a branch or pull request.
It then automatically
starts to build
and tests a new Docker
image and pushes it
to artifact registry--
which is a single place
for your organization
to manage container images
and language packages.
Check out our new series
on artifact registry
in the link below.
And the final leg of the
process is kicked off
once Spinnaker detects the new
image in artifact registry.
From there, Spinnaker
would deploy the image
into a scaled-down
staging environment
for integration testing.
These preliminary tests
allow Critter Junction
to have the best chance
at minimizing failures.
Once those tests
pass, a build engineer
is allowed to flip a bit
and push the new image out
to production where Critter
Junction's audience can
access the new feature.
Between Git, Cloud
Build, artifact registry,
and Spinnaker,
Critter Junction was
able to develop an automatic,
gated, tag-based, continuous
integration and
deployment pipeline that
allowed for faster
iterations, more flexibility,
and reliability for their
containerized environment.
This pipeline allowed
Critter Junction
to smoothly scale
up and quickly add
new features as their
game gained more audience
and acclaim.
Check out the link below
to learn more, and thanks
for joining us for
season three of season
of scale on microservices,
statelessness,
and continuous delivery.
Stay tuned for what's
next for Critter Junction.
And remember, always
be architecting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]